um so thank you so much for having me uh
um i'm in located in halifax nova scotia
where it's uh quite beautiful here today
um
and uh
what i'm going to sort of talk about um
is about uh security uh and how to
kind of like approach um building like
getting your data scientists to work on
data in a secure environment interfacing
with those other parts of the company
and one of the sort of things i was
thinking about while i was sort of
trying to figure out what to say about
this is
that there's not really a kind of
right answer in terms of
how what level of security you need for
any of these systems
um so these are kind of like
general strategies very general
strategies i think the particular things
you need to do like we need this kind of
authentication or the data needs to be
stored in this play it'll play it way or
tracked in some some fashion um are
going to be individual to
the place that you work um so this is
kind of more about like how do you work
with the people and systems at your
company and how do you set those things
up to be successful
um
so
um this is my lovely stove picture uh
and um
some things over
um so a little bit about uh so cure
so sokyar
is an identity company so we build
basically models and data products that
help people identify fraudsters so
whenever you apply for like a bank or a
credit card um you uh your bank sends
your information to
either a company like ours or another
model
or another or an internal model to sort
of check like are you really who you say
you are this is for
um regulatory reasons to make sure that
people aren't like laundering money it's
also for um just loss prevention like
fraud costs companies a lot of money so
they try to do things that um
uh produce that that uh reduce fraud um
and and we're the best at that so we
have we have some of the best products
in in these markets um and uh a lot of
that has to do with the fact that we've
kind of from the start
um
set up systems where we're able to
confidently work with very very
sensitive data of various different
kinds and segregate data that's more
sensitive from data that's less
sensitive
and using those kind of data assets um
we're able to build these kind of um
pretty wonderful models uh we're also
going through a period of very very fast
growth um so where our revenue is is
basically
growing depending on how you count
revenue one and two hundred percent uh
year over year
uh we started the year 120 people we're
probably going to be growing to about
500 people at the end of this year um so
we're hiring that's uh if you're if you
are interested in this area um it's it's
rewarding um and a wonderful place to
work
um and so this has put all this puts a
lot of pressure on
security and because the kind of ways
you have to think about security when
you're growing this fast um are slightly
different from the ways that you can
think about security at a larger
um
company just because you know if you
sort of imagine like so i started at
secure two years ago
and i'm one of the more senior people
there right so all the people who joined
after me have like less context about
you know why do we have things set up
this way what are the risks what's the
threat model all those different things
um but i found it really helpful
environment to sort of learn this stuff
because i think if you can kind of
build secure systems at these sort of
like
fast-growing company places um it really
helps to think about how to
make them work at all different types of
companies
but so that's just a little bit of
context um so
i want to sort of talk about what i i
sort of think of as the bad place the
security bad place
um that a lot of places find themselves
in and this is kind of the basic
conflict between data scientists and
really everybody else um but you could
say similar conflict occurs between like
you know sales people and security
people some some degree like engineers
and security people but definitely data
scientists and security
uh people it's the worst and the basic
conflict is that the safest way to
deal with sensitive data is to just
delete it right to not use it if you
can't delete it you want to make sure
that you don't give anybody access to it
and if you can't give you can't prevent
people from accessing it all you want to
have like a small number of people and
it has to be really really annoying to
access right so they're kind of like the
from a security perspective that's the
hierarchy of
data safety right and as soon as you
have somebody who's actually like i'm
gonna go open up a data set and look at
you know the emails or look at the name
that's a kind of like security
nightmare for people
but from a data science perspective like
there's a lot of
insight that you're getting from that
data that you actually do need to look
at the data um so for example if we have
like fraud fraudster a fraud ring coming
in um they might have like a particular
email pattern which we don't know about
until you actually kind of look at that
those those those scores you look at
them and say like okay like what are the
emails that are
you know causing us to decide this
person is is fraudulent like you know
how does what does that make sense at
some point you maybe can build an
automated system to detect that pattern
but at some point data scientists do
need to actually like be able to look at
the data in some environment
right
um
so what i've noticed um that happens
with security uh
is
the security groups i'm just gonna refer
to that as security like so this is
maybe like compliance people security
engineers you know the people who are
there to try to make sure that your
company doesn't get hacked and you know
your
employees don't leave you know their
laptops at you know at coffee shops with
precious information on them
um
you know so security like they'll come
into a situation
and they'll try to fix something that's
broken that's an old system
that was set up some way that you know
maybe
it was good at the time or maybe it was
just never thought about but it's some
bad old system
and um they'll say like look this is a
big you know problem right like this
could be an attack here we gotta fix
this right but in order to fix they have
to um
direct money from new projects to fix
the old ones and usually like in most
companies like
the groups that are responsible for
security don't actually have the power
to direct resources like that um and so
they have to sort of try to have this
fight between like the value that these
new
things will do versus fixing the old
ones
and oftentimes they don't get their way
and that old fix doesn't happen
um but the power that security does
always have is the power to veto new
things right so when a new project comes
in it usually goes through a security
review and if it fails it doesn't get
put in place right so you have this
situation where like the company can't
fix the old security problems but then
can also put in new systems in place
because they get vetoed right
um and this is kind of like on some
several level like the second the third
one is sort of like partially i think an
emotional reaction to the second one
like people didn't feel heard
about the big problems so they maybe
like enforce those policies like too
strictly for some new systems um
everybody thinks that the other side is
unreasonable like so the data scientists
feel like um security is just putting
roadblocks like needless roadblocks in
their place and they're like this is way
safer than the old thing that we were
doing so why not do this new one
um security thinks that data that that
the rest of the business doesn't care
about security um and then everybody
just stops talking
so
i think this is really common and it's
it's worth knowing that even if this
this isn't like a a real problem at your
business most of the people
who are coming into that business have
had experiences at other companies that
are that are like this so like most
pretty much all the security people i
know
have had situations where they were like
i was at this other job and
there was this like giant you know giant
fire of a bad system that never got
fixed and it was so frustrating and i
left right so they're kind of carrying
that from from job to job um and data
scientists think often feel like we can
do we've had all these experiences where
it's like i could do so much pretty so
much value but i just can't get access
to the data that i need to actually
produce that value
so that's the bad place
um so this is a really big problem
because it it's sort of all of the
friction of a high security environment
with none of the security um because
all of these kinds of hacks are or
security issues they're adversarial
usually so somebody is looking for the
weak link in your company's armor and it
really doesn't matter
if you have if 40 of your systems are
secure or if 90 of your systems are
secure because they will tend to find
the
the holes right so so you kind of want
to always focus your energy on like
lifting the floor of your business
rather than having like some small
number of things that are like super
duper secure um the analogy that i kind
of um
use for this is like if all of your
windows in your house are open you know
it doesn't really matter if you lock the
door right like that somebody a burglar
is gonna like just go through the window
um
and um so you get this sort of system
where you're like you've put in a lot of
friction like a lot of fights your
business can't move very quickly but you
haven't really gained that much in terms
of security over overall
so as a data scientist you can help with
this problem um by kind of trying to
understand and like being intentional
about being an ally to the security
parts of your organization
um because oftentimes um
when you're when a like decision makers
are hearing security issues from several
different places in the company they're
much more likely to be fixed so if it's
not just coming from
the people who are kind of always
bringing up security issues you know
like if it's coming from somebody else
as well like that's a really powerful
way of making progress on these things
and the something that's helped me think
about this is just to sort of like think
about the mindset of somebody who is
whose job it is to identify
low probability risks out of business
right and so this is kind of they live
in this like lonely anxious world like
they're often saying no to awesome stuff
everybody else is like this would be so
awesome and then the security person is
like no we're not doing that that would
be awful
um and there's also just this a lot of
anxiety right like they don't get any
positive feedback right it's like
nothing happens it's not because they're
like oh this is i i did such a great job
right it's just like there's i'm just
constantly worried about these small low
probability things that will happen that
all have missed that will sink the
business right so it's a really like
high anxiety um workplace so it's kind
of like understanding that and
and
like putting yourself in that mindset
when you're talk to people in security
is really helpful um because you can
kind of sort of like talk about like you
know like basically just sort of like
not think of that they're being
ridiculous right like it's often
something where it's like the thing that
seems to you as being like overly strict
is often because like
when you're spend your time thinking
about these you know things that happen
100 times but that are really tragic um
it's uh you're sort of more likely to to
find those things and think i'm going to
think that they're important
um
another good thing to do is just to talk
about security projects so pretty much
everywhere that i've worked um
there's a list of things where it's just
like you know these are
important security projects that we have
not done because for whatever reason
they they just haven't gotten
you know gotten to the top of the pile
um because there's always new things
going on the top of the pile and they
kind of get worse and worse over time um
so being somebody who's kind of just
like not part of that security
organization but is just like aware of
those issues and continues to bring them
up over and over and over again
um helps
the rest of the like compliance security
teams
um sort of realize that you're on their
side when you're talking about building
any of these systems
um
and then do things like um
sort of have one-on-ones with people
just sort of talk to them about like
their job what their what they're
working on develop those things and then
the last one which i think is really
important is that prove that you can
make progress on these things like so
that prove prove to security that you
the data scientist who's handling this
stuff can push these things through and
accomplish them you can start with small
little things that are like security
bad practices on the data science team
like improving those a little bit and
being able to demonstrate that is really
important why is that important it's
important because
when you're setting up a system it
allows you to make promises to security
and compliance groups
and have them believe you so you can say
like we're putting this in place now
because it's better than what we had
before here are the three or four things
we'd like to improve over the next six
months
um and if you don't do this where you
kind of like demonstrate over and over
again that you're gonna like move that
security ball forward
they're going to say no like you we have
to do everything that we all the
requirements today on day one
because i don't trust that you're going
to actually do what you say you're going
to do in terms of of delivering on these
patches basically
um
so if you kind of do all of that like
and sort of start thinking of yourself
and maybe this is like a whole data
science team or maybe it's like a couple
of people on that team so it that's
secure this is something that i've i've
done basically as kind of like a liaison
between the big group of data scientists
and the big group of security people so
now basically like those groups don't
feel like they need to talk to each
other as much like they both can talk to
me and my team and we can sort of
translate and be like you know like have
the context of what the data scientists
are trying to do have this context of
what the security people are trying to
do and be able to like find the the sort
of solution that kind of like works for
both groups
um but once you kind of do that it's
sort of unlocks a lot of the rest of it
but if you can't get out of that bad
place
you're not going to be able to develop
things that are very secure in my
experience you're also not going to be
able to develop things that are
amenable to really productive data
science work
um so this is like i know this is a
little funny spend ten minutes to talk
about like you should be friends with
your coworkers but i work at a tech
company so i think important to do that
um
okay so the
the thing once you kind of have that
relationship like i think it's important
to um
come up with just a list like an ordered
list of security priorities as they
relate to data science
um and this is
it's important to do that and to kind of
like think about this as a
like just to speak in a real basic
language because a lot of times like
people who work in security don't really
have a good sense of like
what it is that data scientists do um
and like what it what like what do you
do day to day right like the programming
the data scientists do is very different
from the programming that you would do
as a like an application software
engineer um it's much more like a
process of discovery than it is a
process of implementation
a lot of those different things
and then these two things that i would
really highlight
are to precisely articulate the business
value of the data science work
and and this is um that's okay like this
is kind of easy on one level because you
know we're a data science company all we
sell are statistical models basically
um so there's we can sort of say in
general like you know our our work is
valuable to the company it's the main
product that we sell but being really
precise about it um helps to
narrow down like what kind of data
access you need so when you're more
precise about the business value that
you're producing you might you might
sort of say like
okay well actually like i can get that
same business value with
you know 10 of the people only 10 of the
people having access to
this sensitive data or i can get that
same business value
with the same sort of like productive
velocity if i'm you know using like this
kind of environment versus this other
one um but being really really sort of
uh like specific about like why do you
need to access this data
um
like why does it like why do you need to
do that what's the value that that
particular piece of access provides to
the to the company um helps you sort of
narrow things down and also like
convince people that that access is
worthwhile right if you can sort of say
like look here's the business value that
this access
grants us um
you're going to have a lot better time
getting that access
um an example of this is sort of say you
have like a database that has um
intermingled
data that's like sensitive and not
sensitive and most of your business
value might be accessing the
non-sensitive data but since you only
have the one
database account right like you can you
kind of by accessing the
unsecured the non-sensitive data you
might also be exposing the sensitive
data um so that's an example of
something where you're like okay if we
like split that data apart you know so
that we put the sensitive data in a
whole other place um you're able to
be more
like just even like you you're the data
scientists are doing the same amount of
work same positive stuff um they're just
like the the collateral access is lower
um similarly from the security side get
them to purchase precisely articulate
the threat model that they're worried
about and this kind of goes back to that
sort of like vague anxiety that people
have which is like you just have this
vague anxiety of stuff and then you just
beat up things because you're just like
i'm just anxious i don't want i don't
want any kind of breach
um but when you sort of are like more
intentional about like what kinds of
attacks are we trying to prevent
um
you have a better chance of kind of like
right-sizing the security access
uh so an example of this is like you
know you might worry about um mistake
from your company like you don't want
your your employees making a mistake and
putting a file in some place that they
shouldn't be putting it
or you might worry that they're
malicious that your your employees are
actually going to try to steal this data
from you and sell it to somebody else
right those are very very different
threat models um and if you
and the systems that you're going to
design that are going to be good for the
first one are not going to be good for
the second one um and oftentimes like
when
security groups will have like some
internal version of that but getting
them to tell you that so that in a way
that you can understand and communicate
to the rest of the people who work with
you
is going to help you
get buy-in from data scientists to use
those systems and also just sometimes
give you an opportunity to kind of argue
back a little bit about
what you really need to do
and then the sort of goal of this is
just like an ordered list of like these
are the big security problems that we
have and we're going to try to go down
this list from top to bottom and fix
them uh and you might be in terms of
priority you might also include some
things like how easy are these things to
do or not
um but coming up with this thing where
everybody's agreeing these are the main
things um and then that's what we're
gonna try to put our energy towards to
fix the
raise the floor for for your security
thing rather than trying to fix the new
ones
um is really helpful
okay so that's all kind of like prologue
these are my three principles for
building secure systems
um one is child proof rooms second one
is developer experience as a slogan is a
security problem and third one is to buy
things and not build them
um let's talk about child proof rooms
this is my daughter's playroom um and
this is kind of like i feel like the
perfect analogy for
what you want to do with data scientist
especially new data scientists who have
just joined your company um you want to
give them a place that has all of their
stuff
that is really nice
and that they can't like burn your house
down right and so there's a place where
you can like just say like go play you
know like go go do your thing in here
and i will make sure i will do the work
to make sure that this room as a whole
is safe so i can like you know
go cook dinner or something like that
but all your books are in here all your
toys are in here you know it's got all
the
cpu and ram that you need
you know and and you can sort of go nuts
um so they're really like places where
people can't hurt the company
um
and this is the only way that you can
onboard people quickly and to have it be
safe
because there's no way
that a new employee in their first month
of work is going to be able to
understand like the
the security and regulatory environments
that soak your operates in like the only
way that we're going to be able to get
them to abide by those policies is if we
kind of make the situation the
environment that they're in
um enforce those policies
so this kind of means that when you
embed put those secure things inside the
the system that you're building um
you don't have to tell people about it
as much right because it's just like
that's just what it is you don't tell
people that the
you know like
that like it's kind of like i don't know
whenever you go into like a really
well-designed
like hospital or something like that
like how you use these various different
things is obvious like there's only one
natural way of doing it and that's kind
of what you're going for you don't want
to have a situation where you're
basically like having people read
100-page policy documents and expecting
that they're
i'm gonna abide by them nobody can do
that um and definitely new people can't
so if you're like so if you think about
like our stuff like we're gonna be
if we have like 100 people starting in
the next three months
we're not going to be able to teach them
how security works like we're going to
be able to build a system such that they
can just drop in there and work and it
is secure and we're confident about that
um but um but there's no way for it to
there's no way to do this without like
having this the thing be kind of like
a child proof you know like it's it's
not it's it's something where they don't
need to be a grown up person at the
company they can just go for it as a
toddler
um so the next one is um
this idea of that developer experience
is a core security problem and so this
is something that i think
is
not well understood by people who work
in security in their day to day um
because people who work in security
come from a model where it's just like
it's kind of like a
a police model or a legal model where
it's like i'll just say what the law is
right like i'll put some policy out i'll
say what the law is and then everybody's
just going to do that
right and like we have like you know we
have really smart thoughtful employees
like the they understand that they're
supposed to be following the rules so
like they'll just they'll just do what i
what we tell them to do and there'll be
some email that goes out and everybody
will read that email everybody will
understand it everybody will be able to
apply it to their experience
um
and you know like they'll just do the
right thing
um
but that's not exactly that's not what
happens because it turns out that like
you just don't have the enforcement
mechanisms for those policies
so
they're
once your company gets even a little bit
big
you're not able to really audit what
exactly everybody is doing
and all the people who you've hired are
like you've hired them because they're
like really clever with computers
and people who are who are really clever
with computers can like sort of subtly
circumvent things that they even if they
might not know that they're not supposed
to be doing something they might kind of
know that they shouldn't do it but it's
like some really urgent project and
they've got to just get something out
the door
right like that people will always sort
of like end up taking some little
shortcuts around um
around something that they find
burdensome right so if the thing that is
secure
is also like a pain to use difficult um
unappealing um some people are gonna not
use it and that's all you really need
it's like some people not using the
secure process
um so you can either make it so that
it's like it's impossible for them to do
the wrong thing like you've put up like
big walls um or you can
sort of understand their motivation
which is that they want to get their
work done as easily as possible
and so
if you assume that they're going to do
the easy thing right and you can make
the right thing easy
then you can
have some confidence that they're going
to
tend to
um could do the right thing right like
if you make it like you put up some
roadblocks around make it super
irritating to
do some process that you think is
insecure and then also give them a
really really convenient way of doing
this more secure process um you're going
to have a lot of success um
with adoption and i actually think from
a security perspective adoption is one
of the big problems it's just actually
like getting people to do the thing
um and and getting them to not like push
back on it so like if you're trying to
get something in place you do often have
to actually go through someone who is
saying like who's listening to their
their teammates to say like um you know
is this actually going to be workable if
it's not workable they'll kind of like
escalate it and have some fight about
whether they should put it in place but
if you kind of
make it so that it's both easy and
secure
you just avoid that whole conflict and
um and it makes the makes it a lot
easier to get these things out the door
um
so um the ways that i've
used to
build good developer experiences for um
for secure projects the first one i
think is really really crucial is to
control the client libraries um so we
have an internal a set of internal r
packages a set of internal python
packages and um
and they're great to use they've gotten
good adoption and so what that means is
that we can we basically have a layer of
abstraction between the user and
however that's interfacing with some
kind of backend system so we might have
like some function that so we have a
function for example that connects to a
database
this function has been around in that
package for years right
but over the over my history there i
think we probably changed
some mechanism of how that database
connection
works maybe seven or eight times right
and that's just like like iterative
things where it's just like okay like
we're gonna
you know do credentials in a different
way we're gonna like use some other you
know tokens whatever um to make that
that access more secure
and the users never knew right like it's
because it's just basically like we
thought about their experience and like
part of their experience is like they
should never have to learn a new
database connection
algorithm like they shouldn't need to
know
how aws like
access tokens work yeah that's not
something that's relevant to their job
like they just want to connect to the
database um and so since we control the
clients we can
make those changes we can first of all
like promise to security like this is
how everybody is connecting to these
databases like here's the state of the
world right now we can tell them like if
you make this change it'll i'll be able
to push that out you know in however
long a week or a day or something
and we can guarantee that once we make
that change everybody is going to be on
the same page and there's not going to
be any user disruption because we can we
know like the scope of that
uh basically the promise that we're
making to the user about like what those
things should do
um
so the
next thing is to like think about
security from like a product sales
perspective like you're actively selling
the product to the user even if at some
point you're going to be able to just
basically say say like
you know like we're not asking anymore
right like this is just the rule like
you know we're gonna do it this way then
it's just that's how it's gonna happen
but to start with actually thinking of
it more like you're selling a product
and one of the ways of selling secure
systems that's really helpful is to say
um
is that most data scientists who work on
sensitive data
um
it just is like freaky like it's just
you do not want to do it it makes you
really nervous you're worried about
leaving it somewhere are you worried
about making a mistake right and so if
you sell them you say like look if you
start using this system like you don't
need to worry about those mistakes
anymore like the system will handle it
for you right so even if it's like maybe
a little bit less convenient to use um
you know like at least you're sort of
like selling to them saying like you
know like you can relax in this
environment you know because it's
because it's the whole thing is more
secure
um one of my first data science jobs was
working on um
the youth criminal justice data uh in
the for the nova scotia government and
uh it was
it was actually under like a air gap so
i had to like work on this like
on this like
like no internet connection computer
with like no r libraries and on some
level it was like really irritating but
on the other level i was like
i was like oh i'm kind of so happy to
just like be here and not have to
worry that i'm gonna like leave this
you know like send like accidentally
email a file and then go to jail right
like so there's some level of just like
comfort of having something that's
secure and so but if you approach it as
like you know like security is just like
making us do this terrible thing right
like you're going to get a lot of
pushback and you're going to look at a
lot of people who are going to find
problems with it rather than helping you
make the system delightful and better
but if you kind of think about it from
the start as like you know we have these
security things that we all care about
and we want to move those forward and
here's the value that you're getting
personally that the business is getting
um
it helps you kind of make progress with
this
um the third one is to pair restrictions
with power so this is kind of like
always ship
security things with functionality
um and this helps a lot right like so if
you
give people something where it's just
irritating right like they're gonna be
irritated if you give you them something
where there's irritation and
like something that they really want
together in some in one release um it
helps kind of make the medicine go down
you know to have something that's like
some new functionality new capacity
that's going with it
and the last one is that looks really
matter so um whenever you're building a
secure system one of the most neglected
things is user experience and design
um and so spending a bit of time just
saying like
you know we're building a secure web
application like let's
you know let's do a sprint with
you know a ux designer and uh like
somebody to make this look nice right
let somebody make this kind of feel
snappy right
um one of the ways that i've kind of
personally worked on this a lot is um
you know we we replace we replace the
number of like kind of like reporting
functionalities that were a little not
secure enough with
some shiny applications
and um
the focus on that is basically just like
it's important to make that application
look good uh even if it's there's no
security benefit at all to that but it's
just something that again like thinking
about this as an external product that
you're selling you want to make sure
that everything is kind of like pleasant
to be around you know like fast enough
snappy enough responsive doesn't crash
and then just like you know doesn't look
like a geocities website from 1992.
do you even have websites in 1992 i'm
not sure
um
okay so i have a little insulated for a
case study about our deer hosts which is
our studio connect um
so
we implemented our studio connect to
host shiny applications
and um
we kind of discovered basically like
that i was putting together a way of
hosting shiny applications using like
docker
and as part of this i went to a
so this went through a security review
and it was vetoed basically because it
was not um it didn't fulfill a bunch of
security requirements and i didn't have
the skills to put those requirements in
place myself
um
and this was kind of one of those cases
where it was like the new system got the
heavy security scrutiny and even though
it was it was probably a step forward
from from a security perspective it
wasn't quite far enough in terms of
getting to where we wanted to go
um
so we also realized that as we were
doing this that we could like yeah so
rcu connect like gave us that
authentication that we needed gave us
the logging tracking auditing
capabilities that we needed um to host
shiny applications but then as we were
kind of using it we were like oh we can
replace a lot of different things with
this like there's a lot of ways that
we're communicating
um what we call like company
confidential information which is not
pii but is you know like things that are
our personal ip that we're worried about
being um out in the world
um and we realized we could sort of like
replace a lot of those things with
hosted our markdown or different things
like that
um
so it was also something that we could
child proof right like we can
build clients to
maybe allow things on
you know one environment and not allow
them on our studio connect uh we can put
on like uh network level controls over
what our ceo connect can talk to um in
the rest of secure systems
uh so it let us sort of put something up
where it's like look if you are you know
hosting something here you know it's
gonna like um be safe safe enough and
and uh it's gonna be like safe and
you're not gonna hurt anything
um
and um it's uh
and it also kind of like let us build
this environment where like data
scientists could deploy things
and we knew that that was okay right so
like this has happened a lot with um
so one of the things i've done a number
of times is like have
uh so our our package has um
like it doesn't have a lot of security
in terms of who is able to download and
install our package it doesn't have any
sensitive things in it um but one of the
ways is we have like functions that will
like refer to a pinned file on our
studio connect or refer to an api that's
hosted on our studio connect and so
there we have like user authentication
on those
files or our apis so somebody can
use a function from the r package and
it'll basically like behave differently
basically they pick up who is that
person
and kind of reference these like you
know connect products and we know that
all of those products are okay
uh because the whole system has been
kind of verified and hardened um so so
we're able to you know host the
different things that we kind of use on
that system
without needing to worry about
um without needing to worry too much
about like the individual products don't
need to be audited and the individual
products don't need to go through a
compliance review every single time
because it's kind of gotten this whole
environment has been blessed basically
uh
and then the last one is uh or the
second last one is it paired
restrictions um which is like you're not
allowed to email the stuff anymore like
you're not allowed to you know this is
you have to share it using this way that
we can track who's looking at every
single document if we need to
um with power you know it's like
reproducible
uh it's you can schedule things you know
that kind of stuff so that led people
like people didn't really notice the
restrictions because we were giving them
something that was so much
more powerful and more convenient in
terms of
their work
and then the last one is that it's just
easy to use and pretty uh and so this
was something that like when we were
looking at it like that's not a security
thing like that wasn't why we bought it
like we didn't we didn't buy it like
from the hosting training applications
like i just needed something that would
authenticate people and log them right
there's lots of different ways that we
could have done that um but this was one
that kind of like did a bunch of other
stuff and also had a really really
pleasant developer experience
and that has been very successful in
terms of people naturally want to use it
and so that means that they're naturally
not doing the other stuff that's not
approved that we don't know about
okay so the last thing i wanted to talk
about was buying software and i wanted
to talk about i wanted to give you an
economic argument about why buying
software is always better from a
security perspective uh and this is an
argument that you can use to get
licensing money from your company um so
at most companies security is a cost
center
what a cost center is something the
company needs to spend money on but
doesn't make revenue based on in the
short term so like you need to spend
money on an office space where you used
to um
you um don't directly make money on that
office the office building right you
make money on the stuff that happens in
that office building
and
different companies have different parts
of their business are cost centers
different parts or revenue centers
but for most of us who work like so so
cure
um doesn't
make secure systems right like we make
we make money off of our models
and like the security stuff to make sure
that we can develop those models safely
and we don't have a breach we don't you
know like like for ethical and business
reasons we don't want to have that to
happen
um that's a cost it's an important cost
it's one we're happy to pay but it's a
cost
so
every business or almost every business
is going to go through rough times where
they don't have enough cash flow and in
those times they were going to cut costs
they're going to neglect cost centers
and they're going to put money into
revenue centers so the place that
actually puts money on the balance sheet
they'll do this even if it's um in the
long run bad idea like even if it's a
long run mistake to cut those cost
centers like cut those security people
cut those you know devops people
when you're kind of get get in a
threatening economic situation or
threatening business situation you just
need to put revenue back on the business
you need to get it back into the black
so you'll tend to neglect cost centers
so
while security is a cost for you
for the vendor it is a revenue center
right so um if you know databricks or
studio
is thinking about like should i
invest in in wrapping this brand new
awesome security protocol right if they
do that there's going to be some
customer out there who's going to buy
their product because they did that
right so they're going to put money and
stuff into
that thing even in like times where
their business is difficult right
because like that's a big part of what
the product is that they're selling like
they're selling something that is secure
something that is compliant something
that works for all these companies that
they're trying to sell to so um so when
you whenever you buy software or license
software
you're basically like
moving security from a kind of from
living in your cost center world so
being in like the revenue center of your
business right because you're kind of
like offshoring it to some degree um so
a little bit it's like a maintenance
commitment to the future about we're
going to keep this up to date you know
like we're buying the software now we're
also committing to paying like license
cpas for the next however long we use
this thing and that's kind of like
putting a little bit of money every year
into
that system getting better and more
secure
so
um this is really important also be if
you're growing uh because as you're
growing your security requirements
change right so the the things that like
so when i put that when i was doing that
review about
what how do we host shiny apps securely
uh that was in the security world of a
small startup that might not make it um
now so qr is uh like we have a billion
dollar valuation uh wearing forbes you
know like we're a much much bigger
target than we were so our security
requirements have changed dramatically
right um
the nice thing about buying software is
that your vendor has other clients has
built these products for clients that
have big company problems right so if
you're a small company you buy these
things right like you might look at it
and you're like well like i don't need
that i don't need that i don't do that
right but as you grow like suddenly you
discover like you need all of those
things
um
and then the the thing about like growth
is that you at some point you start
being limited by people and not money
right so like it takes maybe six months
or something to like hire an onboard
like a new devops person
and we and like we can't sort of just
hire 20 of them all at once
uh so
right now like we're really
grateful for any opportunity where we
can spend licensing money to avoid
development work um because we we have
like tons of development work that is in
our core business that you know there
are no vendors for right um so anything
that we can do where we're able to
basically say like
you know like i'm gonna put like
licensing money onto this problem um
helps us grow right because like we can
just basically like just
keep giving our vendor more cash right
for more licenses and like support for
them for the most part the support like
works itself out relative to if we were
trying to sell these things
or well relative if we're trying to
build these things ourselves
um so our studio server or studio
workbench is a good um case study of
this so when we first implemented this
it was for mostly remote r development
like we were pretty much um
universal our team uh on our stuff so we
wanted something where it was like
giving people more compute power giving
them like uh remote environments so that
people could
um like so that we knew that the data
was um
uh was location safe um and so it could
be like controlled and audited and you
can like shut people's access off stuff
like that
um but like after we bought that system
and started putting it together like so
we could have basically like built this
remote environment our environment with
a number of open source tools right we
could have used the open source or
studio we could have used um you know
just a server with like a terminal right
there's tons of different ways we could
have done this
that would have been cheaper in the
short term
for it
um but basically like after we bought
our studio server like they keep working
on it um and it keeps kept getting
better um so a lot of these sort of like
things that in when we were first
thinking about it were either like not
at all security requirements or things
that we're on are kind of like nice to
have list
like at some point um in our growth
like we would have you know maybe we
were selling something with client they
would have some questions about
you know how is your data science
environment authenticated right and it
would be like
like and it would be something whereas
like if you're for authenticating in you
know way a
like we're not interested if you're
authenticating way b like that'll pass
our
our audit of your of your of your work
right and so there are many times where
basically like because we had bought the
system and basically just kept getting
these patches and updates every time we
just did the little like you know
there's a new release let's just you
know spend two minutes pseudo installing
the new the new release
um we got those things for we've got
those things they weren't free but they
weren't didn't require any work right we
didn't have to do some urgent sprint to
get those out of the box they were just
kind of
the thing had kept like sort of
accumulating features over time
um and it's it's we've we've sold
product based on that uh so it's it's
something where i think
um this is something that's really
underrated about um
buying software is just that they like
you you shouldn't think of it in terms
of like building the short-term thing
and whether it's more or less expensive
to buy or build you should think about
it like
how
how how how do we want to like do we
want to spend the money and commit the
people to maintain the system that we
build forever or do we want to pay
somebody else to maintain the system
that we like do forever um and i think
unless like your
business is that's the thing is actually
like really really core to your company
like you're the best in the world at
that thing
um usually you should try hard to buy
things
um
and then the other one is that that in
addition to this like going back to that
kind of developer experience stuff
that um that you're also they're also
adding like developer experience things
all the time as well right this isn't
true like this is an our studio hosted
event so that's part of what i'm talking
about these are studio things but i
think this is true of really any vendor
um that you're doing usually
if you trust that vendor
they're going to
have more skilled people working on this
problem than you have in-house right so
the product that you're going to get out
of that is better
and the example here is that you know we
we moved several teams to uh be python
teams at secure um for a variety of kind
of like hiring and hiring reasons um
and um
that was something again we kind of just
had out of the box we didn't need to um
like wasn't part of our initial
purchasing decision really at all but it
was something that we had um
[Music]
like that we were able to add and then
that meant that we could just
save a lot of like development work but
also kind of like
centralize access to some of these
things where it's like you're like okay
this is the world that we're working on
we want kind of everybody to adhere by
these things and we have like some
examples where at least for for many
different groups of people it was
successful
um
so those are my uh three principles so
basically like my advice for this and
this is again like there's not very much
here about like you need to have this
technical setup i can answer questions
about that if it's applied although i
think probably there are usually better
people to answer that um but i do think
that this is kind of like an
organizational
social thing uh to a lot of degrees so
like work hard like
developing a relationship with your
security teams where you all feel like
you're on the same team
try to set up child proof environments
or maybe like data science proof
environments or whatever
think about developer experience as a
security problem like if they're not
they're not at odds with each other it's
not like pick security or convenience
like you actually need your secure
systems to be convenient for them to be
successful
um and then last like try hard to buy
things uh and and there's there are good
economic reasons why the one you buy is
going to be better than the one you
build
um and then lastly um we are hiring in
huge numbers uh we have uh um
we have um a lot of people who are
dedicated our developers as well as many
dedicated
python developers and some people who do
both uh so if you would like to hear
more about this if fraud is an area that
you're interested in um
[Music]
please feel free to reach out uh my
information is here and i'm also on the
linkedin group
thank you very much
thank you so much gordon that was
awesome
i feel like that
it's so valuable for so many different
industries right now i'm thinking of a
lot of conversations i've had with
customers in the past who are kind of
like selling even the idea of data
science internally to their teams
where those points are are really
relevant there
um just a reminder people have
questions you can use the
zoom chat here as well but there's also
a slido link where you can ask anonymous
questions
and gordon one that has been upvoted is
how did you communicate our packages to
your security team
oh you might be muted
um so like
like what what in our package is or you
mean like external our packages
it's probably external ones yeah i think
it's just um
probably coming i've heard this from a
few different teams before as well but
um if someone doesn't know really
what r is how do you explain the idea of
packages
yeah so i mean i think like packages are
like you could sort of
think about it like um
i mean javascript libraries they're the
same um so
the way i sort of think about it from a
security perspective um and this is kind
of like another way where
having a robust like internal package is
really helpful
because like i feel like i'm
able to make decisions about
whether a package should be included in
in our work in a way that um
that other data scientists are not
because i've sort of done a fair amount
of just like package development so i
kind of know i can look at packages and
be like how good is this package like
how solid is its development um or like
who developed it right like so if you're
like i'm much more likely to trust
packages that are
maintained by you know a professional
like somebody whose job it is to to
maintain that and one that's that's ad
hoc much more likely to trust ones that
are um popular than ones that aren't
um
so if you're kind of like exposing like
have an internal package that you're
working on that like does almost
everything that people need it to do
you'll be able to make that decision of
just like i'm not going to take on that
dependency
i'm going to do that in base are you do
that using the packages that i already
use
um
and
so that's one piece of it
the other piece is just of um
like
i i would kind of this is kind of like
articulating a threat model that's part
of that where you're basically like
like i think sometimes security people
will worry more about an r package than
they will worry about a javascript
library
even though the javascript library is
probably going to be hacked before the
r1 is
just because of surface area like
there's more
more javascript people out there and
actually like for putting something on
npm or something like that um
like the
um the requirements of doing that are
much lower than than releasing something
to crayon notice crane is not a security
thing at all um but but um
but just that there are these other
places where
we inject dependencies all the time
um and so i would say like the main
thing i would sort of argue for there is
like to try to get kind of like a fair
assessment
like how is it that you use how is it
that we monitor whether somebody is
using the right npm packages or not like
how do we how do we know that those are
malicious okay like we'll do the same
thing um but but but we but if you don't
if you kind of
don't get them to actually articulate
what you're worried about
you know like is it
like is it name like there's something
called name squatting which have there's
a big python
um it wasn't an attack but it was a
thing where you like have
a python package that is like if you
just release a new version of the python
package
you'll install that one even if it's
delicious
um so so there's sort of like name
squatting like there's various different
types of ways that like uh installing an
external library can be dangerous but
just writing down like what particular
ways are we worried about um and then
figuring out how your thing matches it
doesn't matter there's a lot of
different ways you can do that like
having a
internal like air gap package repository
a lot of different ways you can do that
but um but you just kind of want to make
sure that you're not doing this thing
where it's like
because it's like a language that you
don't relate with like it's impossible
for people to imagine building a web
application without npm
right so that's the same for r right so
i'd say finding like that analogy of
just like what these things are and how
they work
is helpful
thank you
i see there's one other question on
slido
that was anonymous how do you deal with
a security team that has less knowledge
on best practice than the data science
team
like the security
probably yeah like the security side
like if you're having something where
the you don't trust your security
engineers of to have super good um ideas
um i haven't ever been in that situation
uh so i don't know
um the
the security of people especially at
secure are very very good um
but
i would say that um
like you have to meet people where
they're at
right um and and people have power
within organizations and you just have
to deal with that power
um so
i think it's um
so i think like
not getting frustrated right and not
like as soon as you start talking to
somebody who has power over a system
as though they're an idiot
right you've lost you're done right
you're not going to make any progress
with that so you need to
um
like
look at their
sort of work look at their stuff and i'm
trying to understand it in a sympathetic
way right and one of the tools that i do
a lot is i kind of like
you're like repeating bad things back to
people is helpful to just be like okay
what's the most charitable way that i
can
say back to you my understanding of this
um and
then like you can sort of take that and
sort of like write down like okay here's
here's what we wrote down as like this
is that requirement this is why we have
it
right this is the motivation for it get
kind of broad agreement on that um and
then sort of like move forward where
you're like this given that this kind of
like fulfills those things
um but yeah like you you can't
um
you can't treat people like like they're
they're dumb um because because uh it
just that's that's again kind of that
bad place where you're you're um
uh like you're not like as soon as
people stop trusting each other like
you're gonna ask for something that's
totally reasonable in six months and
they're just gonna say
man like that jerk i'm gonna say no
right away right there's a lot of
discretion in these things and
i guess the thing i did have experience
with that is like dealing with i used to
be a lawyer and i used to deal with like
administrator like government
administrators
um
and that's kind of like a similar thing
where you're like oh man this is it's so
stupid i have to file this in triplicate
but if i make a big fuss about filing in
a triplicate i'm going to have to do it
three other things so like so you want
to kind of like try to build that
relationship and then over time if you
do have that relationship it's easier to
kind of like educate and bring in
other resources about how to do it
thank you i think that's such a good
lesson in communication in general and
like thinking about like even
when you're sharing visualizations with
like people from the business as well or
i'm checking the chat to see if there's
any other questions um kevin i see you
asked a question which
may have been answered but want to make
sure that i get to that as well do you
want to
provide any additional context
uh yeah of course um
so
yeah other than i guess the rstudio
connect um
that you were using how else what were
other other tools that you were using
for um like leveraging with our studio
to help with your goals with security
yeah those are the two main ones we also
do have um our studio package manager
which we use um i wouldn't say we do
anything particularly interesting with
it um but it's uh it's it's useful um
i've had a good experience with all
those these aren't the only tools that
we use and these aren't the only sort of
layers of security like there's this um
this idea called defense in depth with
security if you want like just many many
layers um so these are but we do use
both of those um and i've been very
happy with them
um
does that answer your question
i think so yes thank you
i just want to open up uh
to anyone who is on and wants to ask a
question live as well if there's
anything that you're still wondering or
anything else you're hoping to get out
of session today
i'm also wondering which external
package that you're using most right now
oh like external like to
uh just like another like our package
uh
i don't know
that's a tough question um i did use
like so pins was one that
um
that i used a lot and this was kind of
something that
we've we stopped doing uh we haven't we
have another thing but for there's this
period of time where we had a
really urgent data storage
change that we needed to make and the
pro the data storage project was late
um and so we ended up using kind of like
pins in our studio connect to kind of
like be a little like
stop gap until we got the the real
solution um and so that's something that
does like i i do i'm such a fan of pins
it's so simple that it's like just
having something where you're just able
to like
like
you know send a file like stereo have it
be like controlled somewhere like have
it on s3 and just have it come back and
cached and it's pretty nice
um
well tatsu i see that you unmuted so i'm
taking that as raising your hand
oh no i
i didn't even realize that i muted um i
actually have to drop out gordon that
was a fantastic presentation and uh
thanks for
for uh
um educating us i really appreciate it
and i kind of
wasn't sure what i was getting into but
i'm sure glad that i i would see your
stuff thanks great
[Music]